aufbruch erneuerung die menschen
mitnehmen das versprechen alle die sich
für den vorsitz der cdu bewerben gute
zwei monate nach der bundestagswahl und
dem für sie verheerenden ergebnis sucht
die union einen vorsitzenden ihr profil
und ihre rolle als oppositionspartei
und zum ersten mal können die mitglieder
über den chef abstimmen und heute abend
haben sich alle drei kandidaten
gemeinsam den fragen der basis gestellt
friedrich merz der laut umfragen der
favorit ist er stellt sich zum dritten
mal zur wahl für norbert röttgen ist es
der zweite versuch und helge braun der
mann aus dem kanzleramt der kam für
viele überraschend dazu er konnte heute
abend überzeugen und wer führt die cdu
aus dem tal dreikampf in der cdu märz
rücken oder braun unser thema in der
phoenix runde
[Musik]
schönen guten abend herzlich willkommen
aus berlin ich darf meine gäste
vorstellen bei uns ist janina mütze sie
ist geschäftsführerin des
meinungsforschungs start-ups ebay und
sie hat zuletzt für den spiegel erhoben
welcher der kandidaten den größten
zuspruch erhält und ich begrüße daniel
dettling politikwissenschaftler und
gründer der denkfabrik institut für
zukunftspolitik ja wer eine neue
führungskraft sucht heutzutage der geht
eigentlich zum headhunter und so jemand
haben wir eingeladen nicolas rost er ist
deutschland-chef der internationalen
personalberatung heidrick & struggles
herzlich willkommen und das auf und ab
der cdu das beschreibt seit vielen
jahren johannes leithäuser er ist bei
uns politikredakteur für die faz schönen
guten abend vor mütze wir haben heute
abend drei kandidaten gesehen drei
männer helge braun friedrich merz und
norbert röttgen wer hat sie denn am
meisten überzeugt in dieser runde ja ich
weiß gar nicht ob meine persönliche
meinung da jetzt so zum tragen kommt die
frage ist ja wer hat da die partei
wieder schafft überzeugt so vielleicht
besser vor mir wer war für sie der
stärkste kandidat die beste performance
gemacht ja ich glaub es ganz spannend
war heute ist wir haben ja gesehen alle
drei kandidaten haben das thema
einigkeit nach vorne gestellt dass die
partei wollte sich nicht als zerrissen
oder
streitend präsentieren und so hat man
sehr deutlich gemerkt dass die
kandidaten sich mal wieder aufeinander
bezogen haben sich gegenseitig auch
bestärkt haben das fand ich sehr
spannend zu sehen das hat natürlich sehr
schwer gemacht eine klare
differenzierung zu finden zwischen den
kandidaten das
ist glaube ich an der stelle noch
ausbaufähig wie man für eine klarere
positionierung sorgen möchte zeigt aber
dass die partei wirklich ernst nimmt
dass sie in diese neue aufbruch phase
eingehen möchte mit einer vereinten
partei an der basis man versucht ja die
mitglieder können jetzt abstimmen ob dem
vierten dezember und dann mitte dezember
könnte ein stück kandidat stattfinden
wenn es keine stichwahl gibt herr
dettling bevor wir jetzt mal schauen wer
jetzt am besten war wir gucken uns
gleich ein paar ausschnitte an
vielleicht erstmal die frage was braucht
die partei eigentlich im moment ja sie
braucht eine integration eine versöhnung
die partei ist gespalten
das haben die letzten wahlen
18 kramp karrenbauer gegen mehr als 21
laschet gegen merz und roetgen gezeigt
von daher braucht es eine versöhnung
integration der cdu und am besten wäre
natürlich ein klares mandat das wären
wir wahrscheinlich dieses mal nicht
kriegen es wird keinen klaren sieger
geben und es wird wahrscheinlich auch
keine klare erneuerung geben weil die
partei sehr verunsichert ist und eher
eine art übergangs kandidaten sucht und
nicht jemanden der die parteien die
zukunft führt aber man ja so sagt die
ganze zeit sagt man braucht auf jeden
fall eine erneuerung das ist ja das wort
immer heraus die was ist denn wenn sie
jetzt den auftrag für hätten sie müssen
jetzt beschreiben den job eines
cdu-vorsitzenden als personalberater was
wäre die wichtigste eigenschaft der
wunderbare aufgabe habe ich leider noch
nicht gehabt aber ich kann im grunde nur
zustimmen das thema
integrationsfähigkeit wird sicherlich
ein ganz ganz wichtiges sein wobei hier
die quadratur des kreises ist dass man
zum einen nach innen wirken und
integrieren muss zum anderen aber nicht
vergessen darf dass man nach außen die
partei vertreten muss und vor allen
dingen natürlich in der opposition ist
das heißt man braucht auch ein angreifer
ein der rhein
integrierende
sozusagen
ausgleichende mensch wird eine völlig
andere rolle in seiner oppositionsrolle
spielen müssen um der partei auch nach
außen profil zu geben das ist also
glaube ich hier das große thema also
herr leithäuser ich würde es gerne ab
und sozusagen die partei streicheln aber
die attacke in richtung opposition also
diese beiden eigenschaften würden sie
das auch so sehen oder ist es dann
besser diese eigenschaften auf zwei
kürze zu verteilen
nein ich glaube das problem ist
tatsächlich dass die kandidaten jeweils
immer nur die hälfte dieser
eigenschaften gut erfüllen friedrich
merz ist sicherlich der angreifer aber
viele bezweifeln und das glaube ich mit
gutem recht dass er der große integriere
sein kann
helge braun ist nach vier jahren kanzler
als minister in der großen koalition der
personifizierte integriere wirkt aber
nicht sehr angriffslustig und zurück
können möchte eigentlich der große
reformer seien aber hat eben wie braun
auch schon darauf verzichtet quasi die
ganze autorität in seiner person zu
vereinen dies in der opposition gibt
nämlich dann auch fraktionsvorsitzender
zu werden und das ist ja dann die bühne
die man am ehesten nutzen kann stärker
als die als parteichef das soll nach
beiderwellen
also weiterhin einfach bleiben wie es
ist und ralph brinkhaus sollte es
weitermachen insofern hat glaube ich der
dating recht spannende wird die
übernächste parteivorsitz oder die
übernächste parteivorsitzende der cdu
werden wenn diese jetzigen kandidaten
dann durch einen nachfolger abgelöst
werden interessant ist dass sie alle von
der darüber reden dass es um der
einigkeit geht dass die union wieder
eine union ist das war auch eine der
ersten fragen die heute abend
angesprochen wird und da wollen wir
gleich mal ein paar ausschnitte zu
zeigen wir beginnen das war die frage
halt eben was kann man gegen diese
zerstrittenheit tun und wir beginnen mal
mit norbert röttgen ich würde sagen es
ist eigentlich noch ein bisschen
schlimmer denn wir haben keine
zerstrittenheit von flügeln was
inhaltliche positionen anbelangt beim
wer ist denn der alfred träger von heute
wer ist denn da heiner geißler von heute
also personen die für unterschiedliche
inhalte gestanden haben und miteinander
gerungen haben ich glaube dass wir das
nicht mehr haben das ist ein fehler von
uns und das wir stattdessen über
irgendwas über posten übermacht über
einfluss streiten und zerstritten sind
und dann das noch in einer weise tun die
einfach den anstandsregeln bürgerlichen
anstatt den regeln bürgerlichen anstands
nicht entspricht durch ja weil das ist
ja auch etwas worauf die cdu immer wert
legt auf die werte auf den anstand und
das ist ja in den letzten wahlkampf oder
nimmt in der zeit bei der
kanzlerkandidatenkür ja doch etwas
hinten runtergefallen da haben sich
viele darüber aufgeregt jetzt haben wir
noch kurz helge braun zu demselben thema
ich bin schon mal sehr froh dass die
flügel gesagt haben weil manche in der
letzten zeit überhaupt haben die cdu
spaltet sich in lager auf und das sind
worte die sollten wir ganz schnell aus
unserem sprachgebrauch streichen wir
haben verschiedene wurzeln soziale wird
liberale wurzeln und konservativen
wurzeln
das müssen wir als stärke begreifen so
wie früher für die cdu gleichzeitig
träger und und geißler gestanden haben
und irgendwie hatten alle das gefühl das
ist trotzdem eine starke cdu und eine
starke cdu trotz verschiedene flügel und
dann werden immer eben alfred dregger
genannt der sehr weit rechts in dieser
partei stand und
heiner geißler der für den sozialen
flügel in dieser partei stand frau mütze
in ihren untersuchungen nach was sehnen
sich dann die mitglieder und die bürger
war was sagen sie welches profil oder
welchen welche welchen teil der cdu
sollte man mir stärken hat das eine ganz
spannende frage weil die nicht einfach
zu beantworten ist also wenn wir die
menschen in deutschland fragen was sie
glauben wie die cdu sich positionieren
muss dann sind sie da relativ gespalten
ob die union jetzt den merkel kurs
weiterfahren sollte oder eben
konservativer werden sollte bei unter
den unionsanhängern sagt jeder zweite er
oder sie wünschen sich eine
konservativere cdu eine mit einem
stärkeren profil in dem bereich es gibt
aber auch da eben 25 prozent sagen das
ist schon alles ganz richtig so wie es
gerade ist also ich glaube das wird
einer der kern herausforderung des neuen
vorsitzenden zu sein da nicht zu sagen
wir machen a oder b sondern zu schauen
wir sind dann eigentlich unsere zukunft
zum wählerinnen und wähler und wo holen
wir die ab und wie schafft man das nicht
irgendwie eine rechte schubladen eine
linke schublade zu packen sondern da
eben an der stelle thematisch zu
integrieren und da gibt es ja
tatsächlich ganz viele positionen den
die union wirklich angreifen kann das
ganze thema
wirtschaftspolitik steuern also vieles
auf was man es im koalitionsvertrag
rente
vielleicht ja auch noch kritisieren und
offenbar ohne diesen begriff konservativ
hostie was zeichnet denn jemanden aus
den mann als konservativ charakterisiert
wenn jemand sagt ich brauche jemand der
konservativ ist wie muss der denn dann
seien
es ist immer sehr die frage aus welcher
richtung dieses wort konservativ
verwendet wird wenn es wirklich im sinne
einer nicht weiter entwicklung
verwendet wird dann wird es ja auch sehr
häufig von gegnern des konservativen
lagers
verwendet ich würde wahrscheinlich schon
sehen dass das thema konservativ erst
einmal bedeutet dass es einige
grundwerte gibt die sich nicht verändern
je nach tageszeit dh das ist im grunde
um dieser kompass ja und wenn ich wähler
bin möchte ich wissen wo es norden bei
dem jeweiligen politiker der politikerin
die ich wählen möchte und diese dieser
nordpol darf sich nicht verschieben wenn
man so will ist das
konservative nämlich festhalten an
einigen grundwerten und grundausrichtung
das heißt die politik wird nicht
beliebig und das ist für mich ein thema
der richtigen flug dass man sich
sozusagen nicht im klein-klein im
tagesgeschäft ständig verliert wir sehen
uns ja gerade in der korona politik
beispielsweise da gibt es überhaupt von
konservativen keine art von konservative
grundhaltung dazu sondern das ändert
sich fast wöchentlich also was wird
nicht sagen wer den kommen was hat wer
hat also von diesen drei kandidaten die
wir da jetzt sehen wer hat den stärksten
kompass im ja im konservativen sinne
naja gut die die naheliegende antwort
wird wahrscheinlich friedrich merz
werden viele erwarten dass man das sagt
andererseits glaube ich dass das
bestreben von norbert röttgen im moment
durchaus ist genau diese eher
programmatischen sammer auf langfristig
orientieren angelegten themen zu
adressieren friedrich merz nennt sich ja
jetzt auch nicht mehr mit seinem team
team märz beispielsweise sondern team
cdu und es gibt sehr sehr viele
beispiele bei ihm war seine meinung
geändert hat ich glaube dass er mit dem
wort konservativ allein auch nicht mehr
assoziiert werden möchte er sieht
einfach dass möglicherweise das
wahlrecht auf 16 jährigen noch
ausgeweitet wird und er mit diesen dem
nicht mehr weiterkommen das heißt ganz
ehrlich gesagt glaube ich dass sich alle
drei kandidaten jetzt erstmal noch mal
den kompass einstellen müssen weil im
moment so ein bisschen die im
überlebensmodus sind also ich sehe nicht
so richtig diese konservative
grundstimmung momentan sondern mehr
sozusagen die nächste interne wahl
gewinnen und dann zu einzelnen themen
aussagen treffen herr leithäuser kann
das dann kann das klappen dass man sagt
man muss auf der einen seite im profil
schärfen und auch klar sagen wofür die
cdu steht und dann aber trotzdem alle
flügel bedienen also von ganz den
sozialen flügel aber den den auch eine
klare nebenwerte konservativen also kann
das funktionieren
und wer kann das am besten mit ich
glaube dass dieses als
aneinanderreihung von positionen
überhaupt niemals hinkriegen ich finde
das also konservativ hat sicherlich auch
was mit
erkennbarkeit zu tun vertrauen ein
gesicht haben und dieses gesicht war für
die cdu 16 jahre lang als
parteivorsitzende noch länger angela
merkel
das ist nicht so ohne weiteres von heute
auf morgen zu ersetzen und dann gibt es
ja immer darauf ist auch gerade ja schon
hingewiesen worden den unterschied
zwischen wählern und anhängern und
mitgliedern ich glaube sicherlich das
für viele mitglieder der cdu also vor
allen dingen ältere männer friedrich
merz das vertraute und erkennbares die
gesicht der cdu ist es gibt aber
sicherlich begründete zweifel daran dass
er gleichzeitig für wähler die die cdu
als volkspartei erhalten sollen das
beste angebot und vertrautes gesicht ist
oder auch nur für die anhänger der
selben und ja er hat tatsächlich
versucht in der letzten zeit etwas
moderner
progressiver und aufgeschlossener zu
wirken mit der vorstellung der leute die
er um sich geschart hat auch mit dem
schwerpunkt auf sozialpolitik den er
jetzt neuerdings für sich ausgemacht hat
und auch in der art und weise wie er
beispielsweise frauenförderung in der
cdu betreiben will
klingt ist das glaubwürdig sie
beobachten ja auch schon lange ist das
klingt es klingt ein bisschen
tisch und ein bisschen bemüht
und ich bin nicht sicher ob das
tatsächlich in den beliebtheitswerten
einen vorsprung verschafft vor den
beiden anderen kandidaten
okay ganz kurzer dettling da kann man
auch mal dazu dettling für eine eine
volkspartei muss sich breit aufstellen
ist die cd oder kann die cdu aber dann
im moment nur sozusagen land gewinnen
wenn sie sich weniger breit aufstellt
wenn sie sich viel klarer für eine
bestimmte richtung also entscheidet wer
wären wir bei der letzten bundestagswahl
gesehen wo die cdu verloren hat sicher
zweieinhalb millionen stimmen verloren
weder stimmen an grüne und spd also sie
hatte ich einen politischen mitte
verloren in der sozialen mitte verloren
da muss sie wieder hin ja und sie hat
ein stammwählerpotenzial von 9 bis 15
prozent sagen die demoskopen ja das ist
etwas oberhalb dessen wo sie gerade
steht also die lage ist ernst und mit
einem kandidaten märz der er für die
gute alte zeit steht ein eher retro
konservatismus ist das nur offene wette
ja und da haben glaube ich wie herr
leute auch sagt viele ihre zweifel also
die cdu muss sich breit aufstellen sie
muss jünger werden sie muss weiblicher
werden sie muss bunter werden sie muss
beteiligungs orientierter werden ja also
wirklich auch die mitglieder wie jetzt
beteiligen vielleicht sogar darüber
hinaus
andere erfolgreiche parteien makro in
frankreich johnson in england beteiligen
auch nicht mitglieder in den usa kennen
wir das konzept der offenen vorwahlen
also in diese richtung muss sich die cdu
entwickeln weil der größte gegner der
größte feind der cdu ist der tod sterben
ja es sterben jede wahlperiode eine
million wähler der leute hat ja auch
gesagt ich fahre jetzt nach der
durchschnittliche zwischen den
mitgliedern über 60 ist männlich also
die haben ein demografisches problem
also sie müssen jede wahlperiode eine
million zusätzlich gewinnen wo wollen
sie die gewinnen die müssen ein grund
hat am ganzen frauen absolut also die
cdu muss wieder eine moderne volkspartei
ja das würde glaube ich herr merz auch
so unterschreiben und die anderen beiden
wahrscheinlich auch die cdu hat vor
allen dingen auch im osten stark
verloren wir hören jetzt auch noch mal
zu diesem thema zerstritten hat was die
cdu besser machen kann wenn man
friedrich merz bitte ich finde dass wir
uns auch besonders um die ostdeutschen
länder kümmern müssen da haben wir große
defizite wir haben aus den fünf neuen
ländern jetzt lasse ich berlin mal außer
betrachten nur noch 21 abgeordnete der
cdu im deutschen bundestag und das zeigt
in welcher verfassung wie auch dort sind
was den umgangsstil miteinander betrifft
ich möchte dass das aufhört dass aus
diesen sitzungen live berichterstattung
in der bild -zeitung stattfindet ich
werde in den sitzungen darum bitten dass
alle ihre handys draußen lassen und dass
wir mal wieder vertraulich und
vertrauensvoll zusammenarbeiten und dann
sprechen in dem zusammenhang das
verhältnis zur csu an so wie das in
diesem jahr war darf sich das nicht
wiederholen
bleiben habe vor über die csu reden
bleiben wir noch mal bei dieser bei der
frage des ostens frau müsse die cdu hat
stark verloren an die afg die afg hat
gerade auch in sachsen viele wahlkreise
direkt gewinnen können warum gehen die
leute dort zur afg und bleiben nicht bei
der cdu der das erstmal ganz wichtig den
blick darauf lenken weil er hier auch
gerade eine diskussion durchgeklungen
ist friedrich merz sei nicht derjenige
der in der gesamtwirtschaft zieht das
sehen wir in unseren daten anders also
friedrich merz ist schon derjenige der
im relativen vergleich der drei
kandidaten als der umfragekönig
hervorgeht er wird als der führung stark
wahrgenommen als jemand der für eine
klare positionierung steht und er zieht
am ehesten auch die potenzial wähler aus
dem bereich der liberalen aber eben auch
der ard so daliegt natürlich auch ein
großes chancen fällt für die union und
die frage ist ob das diejenigen die dann
eben abstimmen auch so sehen so
aber er ist natürlich steht auch ganz
klar für die alte westdeutsche cdu
sitzen ja und aber auch da diese
wählerschaft gibt es ja heute noch und
wir haben ja auch einen demografischen
wandel der heißt dass nicht jeder in
dieser legislatur auch eine millionen
neue wähler dazu kommen sondern das
verhältnis geht ja in richtung der
älteren bevölkerung relativ gesprochen
also natürlich hat die cdu dann
zukunftsproblem aber es ist nicht so
schmerzhaft und kann ich auch nicht so
spürbar schmerzhaft wie die kandidaten
ist jetzt hier angesprochen haben aber
dann gibt es konkret gründe warum man
sagt warum im osten so viele stimmen
verloren gehen für die cdu
ja wir sind natürlich dass in vielen
teilen im osten die auf die einfach
stärker ist und dann ganz anderen boden
für sich gewonnen hat
das hat sicherlich viele gründe ist aber
gerade für die union ein problem die
damen am meisten stimmen verliert da hat
corona jetzt an der stelle auch nicht
geholfen das sehen wir auch und ist
sicherlich völlig richtig dass die union
sich stärker darauf fokussiert hey leute
was kann die union tun damit sie im
osten mehr stimmen bekommt
also die die frage ist ja wenn die union
jetzt überhaupt sucht sucht sie jemand
der
in vier jahren sich als kanzlerkandidat
hinstellt und dann auch um diese
ostdeutschen stimmen wirbt oder sucht
sie einen internen party organisator der
ihr nach 16 regierungsjahren zu frischen
ideen einer neuen anmutung und
mehr interesse verhilft das eine ist
eigentlich mehr einen job für einen
generalsekretär
das ist die stelle auf die sich norbert
röttgen und
helge braun wir haben das andere ist die
stellung für einen kanzlerkandidaten die
aber jetzt eigentlich gar nicht
ausgeschrieben ist das ist die stelle
auf die friedrich merz ich gerne
bewerben würde und ich
sagte na
ja also wir haben ja immer diese
beliebte formulierung schließen sie aus
dass beschließen sie ist auf jeden fall
nicht aus und nun ist die sache wenn
beides verbunden wird wenn also der
kandidaten als auch mit einer erneuerten
cdu antritt die wir heute bei diesen
bewerbungsrunden gehört haben sich für
einwanderungspolitik öffnet die jünger
und jünger und bunter wird dann kann ich
mir vorstellen dass diese kombination
viele ostdeutsche welle die bislang afd
gewählt haben wurde die beim letzten mal
auf die gewählt haben genau so
verschreckt und wenig attraktiv macht
wie es jetzt der fall gewesen ist und
die lage wird in vier jahren natürlich
ohnehin eine ganz andere sein weil die
jungen talente die jüngeren talenten
diese der cdu auch noch gibt
beispielsweise ministerpräsidenten wie
herr hans im saarland oder günther in
schleswig holstein oder herr wüst in
nordrhein westfalen falls der seine wahl
gewinnt im nächsten jahr alle haben
nächste jahr nächstes jahr alle von den
landtagswahlen die werden dann viele
hoffnungsvolle kandidaten seien für eine
kanzlerkandidatur als die drei die heute
sich da präsentiert haben herr rossi wie
wichtig ist es dass man sozusagen mit
dieser bewerbung für den parteivorsitz
auch schon sagt ich will auf jeden fall
kanzlerkandidat werden also dass man so
die lange die lange -möglichkeiten im
blick hat oder wäre es ehrlicher zu
sagen okay wir machen es erstmal
parteivorsitz und dann schauen wir das
mal
also die antwort ist letzteres und ich
kann nur beipflichten
also erstmal ist das gefährlichste das
wissen wir alle und das wir sind alle
politiker ist kronprinz zu sein der
lange zeit das hat noch nie gut gegangen
und in der regel deswegen wird die k
frage ja in der regel auch eigentlich
erst kurz vor dem urnengang beantwortet
aus gutem grunde die erfahrung zeigt
einfach dass das sicherlich nicht klug
ist so etwas früh zu äußern aber ich
finde er lotto etwas sehr gut es eben
gesagt das ist natürlich am ende erst
mal um das anforderungsprofil geht und
darüber wird zu wenig geredet es wird
immer gesagt wenn finde ich besser bin
finde ich gut bei einer personalsuche
beispiel für ein unternehmen würde man
erst mal sagen in welchem
geschäftszyklus befindet sich das
unternehmen im moment sind wir im
wachstumszyklus oder sind wir wie zum
beispiel hier in einem
restrukturierungsfonds habe sich nicht
gewehrt noch nicht wir müssen noch nicht
in der insolvenz
nein wir sind nur hier hat herr merz mal
vielleicht sie nicht gesagt aber wir
sind in einer restrukturierung ich
glaube so viel kann können wir schon
sagen dass ein großes vakuum
hinterlassen worden ist nachdem nach 16
jahren merkel und dann brauche ich
eigentlich ein restrukturierungs manager
hat 12 ich glaube schon auch ich brauche
oppositionsführer also diese zwei dinge
wenn ich nur zwei kernkompetenzen raus
greifen würde dann sind das die und
gegen diese kompetenzen würde ich die
kandidaten messen dann habe ich immer
noch lange nicht den idealen kandidaten
aber dann muss ich mich natürlich
irgendwie für jemanden entscheiden und
ja und ich glaube da wird man die
kriterien mal zusammentragen und dann
fällt eigentlich relativ automatisch
irgendjemand daraus ich bin im übrigen
der ansicht dass es noch sehr viel
bessere und viele kandidaten gibt die
wir jetzt noch alle nicht kennen denn
vielleicht kommt der dritte aspekt noch
dazu wir brauchen ein talentförderer
also jemand der wirklich in den nächsten
vier jahren ein richtig gutes team unter
sich aufbaut und nicht nur sozusagen
window dressing macht indem man sich
jetzt
vor allen dingen gender diversity
reinhold sondern vor allem wirklich gute
frauen eine bemerkung möchte noch machen
wenn wir so ein bisschen vergessen ist
die rolle zum beispiel von der frau
prien finde ich hochinteressant die sich
jetzt wirklich nicht vor den karren
spannen das von keinem der drei herren
sondern einfach sagt ich kandidiere
unabhängig und selber als vize und da
zeigt schon dass ich es
selbstbewusstsein da ist in schleswig
holstein ich glaube davon werden wir
sehr viel mehr in der nächsten zeit
werde und ich hoffe dass wir immer das
wird so etwas zugelassen wird und
gefördert das wir ist ja die frage herr
dettling auch in diesen vermerk hat ja
auch betont wir müssen ein team sein wir
wollen und irgendwie modern aufstellen
auf die frage nach der doppelspitze aber
alle drei kandidaten gesagt das passt
nicht zur cdu also so modern will man
dann irgendwie doch auch nicht sein also
wie muss man sich aufstellen dass man
sagt man will auch die art wie man dann
führt das ist wichtig um sozusagen noch
mehr menschen eben dann mit zu nehmen ja
doppelspitze heißt er bei der cdu
parteivorsitz un generalsekretär in dem
fall drei männer für den parteivorsitz
generalsekretär innen sind dann frauen
das wäre quasi eine
ja ja genau dies muss auch erstmal durch
die satzung bringen wird auch nicht so
einfach aber beide alle drei haben das
natürlich verstanden dass es hier eine
ein splitting geben muss was diese
verantwortung angeht was diese
verteilung angeht aber so modern ist die
cdu nicht dass ich jetzt eine echte
doppelspitze wie die grünen oder die spd
das praktizieren interessant finde ich
eher gerade in der opposition eine art
jobsharing rollen sharing parteivorsitz
fraktionsvorsitz drücken relativ klar
gesagt dass er sich das vorstellen kann
also er muss nicht fraktionsvorsitzender
werden ich glaube nicht dass er das
anstrebt sondern er will ihren splitting
weil die abteilung attacke gegen brown
auch abteilung attacke
oppositionsführung ist im parlament ist
der fraktionsvorsitzende oder die
fraktionsspitze und der
parteivorsitzende kümmert sich daneben
um die restrukturierung der partei da
hat er genug zu tun und dass wir
eigentlich ein modernes verständnis in
meinen augen also nicht alles auf eine
person projizieren das ist nicht mehr 21
jahrhundert das ist auch nicht mehr in
der wirtschaft moderne führung sondern
versuchen das auf breite schultern
aufzuteilen und dann auch die vielfalt
der partei quasi auch abzubilden und
wenn ich dann aber sagen ich eine
volkspartei sein weil die doch
eigentlich ja oder ja dann erst johannes
leiter bitte
nicht wenn den kurzen einmal machen das
entwertet natürlich die position der
generalsekretär in dann vollständig weil
die öffentliche aufmerksamkeit spanne
ist schon strapaziert wenn sie sich auf
zwei leute in der opposition
konzentrieren muss und wendeln der
vorsitzende der organisator ist dann
bleibt eigentlich für die
generalsekretär in die doch hierzu
hervorgehoben sein soll gar nicht mehr
so viel übrig es gibt enorm viele themen
also die gefahr sehe ich nicht also sind
kann auch sehr stark von der
generalsekretär in abkommt kam dauerte
sehr gut gemacht damals als
generalsekretär als parteivorsitzender
weise überfordert also ich die gefahr
also ich nicht sehr stark von der person
ab wenn ich mich als volks bald
herausstellen will dann ist es ja
wichtig dass ich auch sozusagen auf
allen ebenen sozusagen auch die
bevölkerung widerspiegelt das tut die
cdu im moment nicht wenn man sich wie
wenig frauen dort engagiert sind womit
sie gaben sie erhoben wie frauen die
union beurteilen und wie frauen auch
diese kandidaten mit die darauf schauen
haben sie dazu untersuchungen ja es ist
ein irrglaube zu denken dass frauen
nicht auch männer wählen oder nicht auch
nicht auch damit fein sind dass ein mann
der spitzenkandidat ist als wir haben
auch im wahlkampf als beispielsweise
keinen frauen bonus für annalena
baerbock wahrgenommen das ist nicht der
fall in gab es aber für angela merkel
glaube ich den gab es in teilen war für
angela merkel er aber das hängt auch
häufig damit zusammen dass das war auch
zu einer zeit in der angela merkel lange
im amt war sehr als der führung stark
wahrgenommen wurde als sicherer hafen
als sie wissen sie kennen mich und sie
wissen wofür ich stehe
dass das hat auch bei frauen gut
funktioniert die union hatte ein problem
sie adressiert ist auch dass adressieren
alle drei kandidaten auf
unterschiedliche art und weise man muss
aber dazu sagen das ist nicht das
kernanliegen und das kern gewinnerthema
unter den und für die unionsanhänger das
ist nicht das thema und
das alleine als auch mit wird mit mehr
gender diversity wird man wahrscheinlich
auch nicht in der partei dann gewinnen
aber was wäre denn wichtig also wie
könnte man den frauen adressieren
es ist ja tatsächlich heute auch
gefallen dass ein schrittweises
quotensystem reinkommen soll ich glaube
da da spricht man sehr unter vorbehalt
aktuell truppe das natürlich auch nichts
was in der in der union so erlernt ist
das ist natürlich etwas was über einen
der etwas veränderung schafft also
wieder veränderungsprozess muss er
gemessen werden muss an zielen gesetzt
werden und so etwas schafft man auch mit
beispielsweise mit quoten das kann
funktionieren mit der sichtbarkeit von
mehr frauen kann das auch funktionieren
da haben wir diese role model thematik
ich glaube aber auch nicht dass jede
frau oder auch jedermann immer gleich im
spotlight stehen muss und quasi die
aufmerksamkeit auf sich ziehen muss also
auch als als generalsekretär in der
generalsekretär auch sehr mächtig sein
in dem man eben wirklich die partei
erneuert und auch das kann er dann in
vier jahren auch zu einer anderen
position führen und trotzdem das ist ja
eigentlich ein armutszeugnis dass ich
keine frau bereit erklärt hat als
parteivorsitzende eine frau gab es die
butter nicht von ihrem kreisverband
nominiert hätte also wie erklären sie
sich dass das es so schwer ist und dass
keine frau lust hat parteivorsitzender
der cdu zu werden bis auf eine frau die
dann aber den rückhalt frau bruder nicht
er hat von ihrem kreisverband
ich glaube die antwort ist ganz einfach
weil es so wenige davon gibt und weil
diejenigen die es gibt sich nicht
genügend unterstützt fühlen um sowas zu
riskieren und man muss ja sehen die 3ds
jetzt versuchen haben alle schon mal
führungsämter innegehabt waren entweder
bundesminister oder waren
fraktionsvorsitzende die haben eine
basis auf der sie stehen und so weit
geht der wunsch nach erneuerung dann
doch nicht dass
man sagen könnte die partei ist jetzt in
einer lage wo sie eine nur mäßig
bekannte
persönlichkeit eine frau
akzeptieren würde als vorsitzende es
gibt immer den hinweis schließlich habe
es jetzt zwei vorsitzenden nacheinander
gegeben frau merkel und frau karrenbauer
aber im falle kam k s ist es
schiefgegangen die hatte übrigens als
eben im gegensatz zu frauen die jetzt
kandidieren könnten diese herausgehobene
position weil sie vorher
ministerpräsidenten war und ich glaube
von merkel war eine ausnahmeerscheinung
und hat die partei übernommen in einer
lage in der sie so am boden lag dass
kein man sich zugetraut hatte sie
weiterzuführen das war im jahr 2000 ist
schon ein bisschen her herr dettling
haben sie den eindruck dass frau merkel
da für die frauen dass es sogar jetzt
negativ wirkt wenn man das geführt ja
wir hatten doch jetzt ganz lange eine
frau darauf gut dass ruden sich ja auch
viele in der cdu auch sei wir hatten
doch solange eine frau und dass man das
sie dazu wenig für frauen getan hat das
glaube ich nicht als wir uns am kamen da
wollte sie unbedingt dass die cdu den
familienminister bzw die
familienministerin stellt aber seinen
ersten großen koalition mit der spd das
war ihr besonders wichtig sie hat die
partei da auch modernisiert verbot
politischer
und am ende sich sogar als feministin
bezeichnet als
positiv aufgenommen und sie auch
deswegen gewählt also denke wie es
braucht jetzt vielleicht auch in
feministischen partei männlichen
parteivorsitzenden der cdu
am ersten norbert röttgen haben wir es
norbert röttgen
galt jahrelang auch als merkels klügster
ist ja sehr lernfähig sehr belesen sehr
zukunftsorientiert ist er ein zukunfts
politiker der nach vorne schaut manchmal
auch zu weit nach vorne schaut für viele
sicherlich aber er könnte das darstellen
holz person hat er heute auch das
familienbild schluss eine runde wo jeder
ein foto zeigen sollte und jan klare
botschaft er hat ein foto gezeigt von
seiner 18-jährigen tochter den
geburtstag der achtzehnten geburtstag
seiner tochter und seiner frau
wir haben
wir wählen heute nicht mehr alleine ja
wir werden heute nicht mehr alleine auch
der männliche
cdu-mitglied wählt nicht mehr einsam da
zu hause sondern da gibt es ein
enkelkind oder eine tochter oder kinder
familie ehefrau die diskutieren damit ja
und entscheiden da auch mit wir wissen
aus der konsumforschung aus der
marketingforschung dass die meisten
kaufentscheidungen von frauen getroffen
werden in den familien ja und das ist es
mit den politischen stimmen auch also
solche reden viele mit und von daher
spielt das thema eine enorm große rolle
also wir die kompetenz hat bei
gesellschaftspolitischen themen es
könnte sein dass die im weiblichen dass
die frauen der vielen männlichen
mitglieder dann auch mitbestimmen wer
dann zu hause online abstimmt wenn man
über den online abgestimmt wird das
lässt sich wahrscheinlich nicht eben
psychologisch
das ist natürlich trotzdem so dass die
wählerschaft sie für diese wahl
mehrheitlich männlich ist und da
natürlich auch in der alterskohorte
anders aufgestellt ist und natürlich hat
jetzt auch das zeigen eines
familienbildes nichts um nicht unbedingt
was mit gleichstellung in der partei zu
tun also das ist ja auch was würden sie
denn sagen um noch mal auf die stärke
der einzelnen kandidaten zu kommen was
ist die stärke von norbert röttgen
er wird wahrgenommen als derjenige der
dialog bereit ist der hohe
fachkenntnisse hat sowohl er als auch
helge braun sind nicht so bekannt wie
friedrich merz das sehen wir eben auch
dass viele menschen ihnen dann auch
nicht so richtig einordnen können aber
die ihn kennen die schätzen ihn für die
fachkenntnis und die dialogbereitschaft
das ist damals sogar die
dialogbereitschaft die haben reicht
heute auch bei armin laschet gesehen
also gab es ja immer auch dieses bild
regiert geräuschlos und einer stimme
mehrheit und diese dialogbereitschaft
die hatten sich noch nicht weit gediehen
dass man einen gewissen position eben
auch eine führungsstärke erwartet und
das ist natürlich etwas was wir aktuell
dann also die menschen aktuell friedrich
merz zu schreiben aber laschet hat den
fehler gemacht dass sie sich friedrich
merz in sein team geholt hat er hat sich
den brutus in sein eigenes
familienmodell cdu eingelegt und das war
ein fehler der hat so ein zwei fehler
gemacht ist ja
noch mal auf die einzelkandidaten
er wusste was würden sie sagen was ist
die stärke von norbert röttgen wenn sie
den an ein unternehmen vermitteln müssen
ja er ist ein
allrounder er aber das ist genau das das
ist auch leider genau seine schwäche ja
denn das thema kannte das ist natürlich
etwas was am ende des tages auch wichtig
ist offen gestanden bei einem politiker
meines erachtens mehr als wenn ich ihn
in ein unternehmen vermitteln würde ich
glaube dass er in einem unternehmen
sogar recht gut reinpassen würde aber
das andere thema ist ja wie weit kann
ich leute emotionalisieren
wie weit kann ich überhaupt biete ich
auch eine eine eine fläche mit der ich
mich irgendwie auseinandersetzen kann
und er sagt immer das richtige ist
sicher intelligent ist unglaublich
geschlichen ob das überall ankommt wage
ich zu bezweifeln zu wenig macht aber
wenn ich darf noch mal ganz kurz was
zum thema frauen sagen und auch da
parallele wirtschaft ich finde das schon
eine sehr interessante diskussion hier
wir haben diese diskussion ja in der
wirtschaft schon vor einigen jahren
hinter uns gebracht mit der quote und
ich erinnere mich sehr gut als die das
thema quote kamen das war eine ähnliche
diskussion wie die anschnallpflicht in
autos und
inklusive mir waren eigentlich alle
dagegen war sagte welche frau will schon
eine quotenfrau sein wir haben wirklich
durch diese quote eine veränderung
zunächst mal in den aufsichtsräten
hinbekommen 30 prozent und wir kriegen
jetzt auch ganz klammheimlich und das
sehe ich in meiner täglichen arbeit auch
eine veränderung so langsam bis wir
sozusagen den sogenannten tipping point
erreicht haben auch im management hin
und bei einer politischen situation wo
ich wirklich 50% wählerinnen und wähler
habe und sehr sehr viele aspekte auch
für männer wichtig sind dass frauen dort
mitregieren finde ich das eine fast
schon
anachronistische diskussion hier nicht
wirklich sich eine quote zu verschreiben
offengestanden innerhalb der cdu weil es
wird sich einfach zu langsam was er in
alles wird sich was ändern aber es
dauert zu lang und ich glaube schon dass
man hier mal ein bisschen in die in die
wirtschaft reingucken sollte wo man ja
eigentlich sehr viel mehr
beharrungskräfte hat im thema also
unabhängige entscheidungen treffen zu
dürfen also gute erfahrung mit der quote
in der wirtschaft könnte die cdu auch
gebrauchen herr leithäuser noch mal
welche stärke hat herr röttgen und herr
braun vielleicht können sie bei mit
blick auf die zeit für beide mal
sprechen wo da die stärken eigentlich
sind ja
bei der einschätzung von norbert röttgen
die es bisher gab wirklich milde
widersprechen wollte nicht aber auch ich
glaube dass er auch kannte kann aber
dass er sich damit seiner eigenen
intellektualität manchmal selber im weg
steht das versteht dann viele dort
stehen dass da nicht so richtig als
kannte weil es ihnen zu kompliziert ist
ich glaube helge braun
die bilder sind ja schon angesprochen
waren oder die fotos die alle drei
mitbringen sollten und das von helge
braun fand ich auch sehr bezeichnend der
hatte so jubelnde cdu aktivisten auf
diesem foto und eigentlich zwar tritt er
auch an mit diesen reformversprechen
aber eigentlich ist die botschaft die er
aussendet doch wenn ihr mich wählt dann
tut es nicht so besonders wie es bleibt
doch alles sehen die gemütlich und zum
release ist also keine rückwendung so
zum
liberal-konservativen wie bei friedrich
merz aber eben auch keinen aufbruch in
dessen zuge man sich dann mit also zu
viel modernität
auseinandersetzen müsste sei es bei
was weiß ich sexuellen orientierung
fragen beispielsweise oder anderen
dingen auch
beispielsweise
wollten
vollzeiterwerbstätigkeit von frauen die
viele von den älteren männlichen
cdu-mitgliedern dann doch ein bisschen
erschreckend finden jedenfalls wenn sie
im square im herzen unterstützen ist
hellbraun die rache des establishments
ja der ist ja wie ein kaninchen aus dem
hut gezaubert worden ja alle haben
gedacht es wird ein zweikampf und dann
kam helga brauchen wer hat eigentlich
jährige brown ermutigt diese kandidatur
anzutreten das ist interessant
ja da hat er absolut aber ist
wenn bin märz nicht gewinnen sollte wird
es wahrscheinlich seinen spin sein was
ihm wieder jemand reingegrätscht hat ob
es merkel war oder profi in hessen die
ihnen da helge braun rein gesetzt haben
weil märz muss den ersten wahlgang
gewinnen wenn er den ersten wahlgang
nicht gewinnt der streit von brown an
röttgen
das hat er war braun ja selber gesagt
dass er also auf dieser
kreisvorsitzendenkonferenz die ist zum
wundenlecken gegeben hat nach der
verlorenen wahl von so vielen
kreisvorsitzende angesprochen worden sei
und ermutigt worden sein und das war ja
also die die kreisvorsitzende der cdu
sind sicherlich das establishment der
partei basis
etablierter kann man gar nicht sein
insofern stimmt die these ein bisschen
die herr dating da gerade aufgestellt
hat okay noch einmal die letzten fünf
minuten und zu gucken wer wird denn
jetzt wer hat die meisten chancen eine
frau müsse nach ihren untersuchungen was
also es gibt die frage zum einen die
wähler und also die bevölkerung und die
mitglieder sind die auch mal gefragt
also wer wird wenn sie jetzt werden
müssten wer wird parteivorsitzender also
die mitglieder haben nicht befragt
das ist sehr schwierig aber wir haben
repräsentative befähigung anhänger dass
man sich ihre anhänger und da sehen da
jeweils das märz führt und eben diese ja
auch die meisten kompetenzen quasi für
sich gewinnt die wir abfragen aber es
gibt auch gerne unentschieden tun es
gibt noch eine menge unentschieden und
es zeigt auch es ist diese dieser
auswahl der drei kandidaten ist jetzt
nicht für alle die beste auswahl der
drei kandidaten man haben kann also das
sehen wir auch ob es jetzt aber reicht
das märz relativ gesehen in der
anhängerschaft in der gesamtbevölkerung
der stärkste ist kann ich nicht
beantworten da denke ich wird auch bei
den mitgliedern vieles mitschwingen wie
kann dieser vermeintliche heilsbringer
kann dann endlich auch die organisation
mit sich ziehen wie seine organisation
verankert
polarisiert auch stark bei den leuten
die nicht cdu anhänger sind glaube ich
oder das stimmt aber wie gesagt er hat
tatsächlich auch einfach gute chancen
auch neue wählergruppen oder ehemalige
bilder gucken hierzu union
zurückzuziehen im konservativen lager
also gibt's das ist eine frage wohin
möchte die union ruhig die cdu als
partei und kann sie da geschlossen
mitgehen das konservative spektrum im
engeren sinne sind neun bis 15 prozent
das sind die stammwähler der cdu das ist
nicht viel ja das ist das eine
splitterpartei oder eine sekt ihrer
partei das reicht nicht also dass sie
müssen in die mitte ja und da ist die
offene frage ob das mit märz gelingt ja
und die cdu sei eine sehr emotionale
partei auch wir morgen den zapfenstreich
der bundeskanzlerin den werden sich alle
anschauen die lieder sind ja auch sehr
emotional rausgewählt ja und dann haben
wir weihnachten und neujahr und dann
beginnt eine neue ära für die cdu aber
dann merkte definitiv nicht mehr da ist
sondern ständig scholz darum rennen der
marke imitator genau
dann will man vielleicht doch wieder
etwas mehr zukunft wagen und also von 30
offene sache
offene sache ich glaube es wird eine
stichwahl geben und dann wird
wahrscheinlich recht können die nase
vorn haben ok heraus sie was denken sie
denn wer da die nase vorn hat
ja wir haben glücklicherweise eine
demoskopen deswegen und ich mich den
wahrscheinlich an schließen aber
noch eine kleine bemerkung man darf
nicht vergessen letztlich wenn die cdu
in vier jahren 30 prozent holt dann ist
es schon gut auch da wieder der
vergleich wenn sie einen ein
vorstandsvorsitz besetzen würden dann
reicht das nicht aus also sie müssen
schon in gewisser weise auch ein
bisschen polarisieren und
und ich finde auch ein bisschen auf
lücke setzen und das sehe ich
tatsächlich im moment bei dem friedrich
merz am ersten und was und bieten sollte
dann der gewinner mit den verlierern
umgehen kann er die einbinden oder muss
er sich dann sehr stark davon abgrenzen
muss ja in binden es bleibt gar nichts
anderes übrig und das haben wir ja auch
immer wieder gesehen das ist danach
meistens zu verbrüderungen und angeboten
und handreichungen kommt und es wird es
auch hier wieder geben mit absoluter
sicherheit den eins haben sie alle
begriffen das schlimmste was der partei
passieren kann ist wenn sie im
außenverhältnis zerstritten auftritt das
hat bis jetzt schon jede partei gekillt
und jeden parteivorsitzenden leithäuser
wer wird cdu-vorsitzender und wie geht
die csu dann damit um
ja ich glaube dass also friedrich merz
derjenige ist der am stärksten stärksten
mobilisiert und am stärksten polarisiert
deswegen glaube ich dass er ganz sicher
in den zweiten wahlgang kommt so wie das
in den letzten beiden malen wo er
kandidiert hat auch der fall war 8000
mitglieder sind neu in die cdu
eingetreten sagt die partei die haben
das nicht gemacht weil sie den
wettbewerb jetzt so schön fand ich
glaube dass die meisten haben es gemacht
weil sie märz unterstützen wollen ob
merz dann aber den zweiten wahlgang
gewinnen kann auch gegen
die skeptische grundströmung in der
partei ob er wirklich die zukunft bringt
da bin ich auch skeptisch das könnte
dann am ende doch knapp für norbert
röttgen ausgehen man muss ja unterliegen
eingebunden werden ja ich glaube dazu
ist alle bereits
und dann ist der nächste
richtig genau und aber wie gesagt dass
glaube diese messe ist glaube ich auch
noch lange nicht gesungen denn bis dahin
wird es junge hoffnungsvolle
ministerpräsidenten geben teilweise zwei
wahlen gewonnen haben in ihren ämtern
und
markus söder muss auch erstmal eine wahl
gewinnen und wird sich ansonsten ein
bisschen abgearbeitet haben schon in
bayern an den verhältnissen und an der
cdu mit köpfen die dann noch junger und
unverbrauchter und vielleicht doch auch
konservativ sind das sales seiner vielen
dank ihnen für diese diskussion hier
leid was die pfütze und herr dettling
vielen dank irgendwas interesse und fürs
zuschauen der große zapfenstreich für
angela merkel findet morgen statt wurde
hier heute schon erwähnt und wir schauen
aus diesem anlass morgen abend dann auch
nochmal auf 16 jahre kanzlerschaft
angela merkel zurück seien sie dabei
wird bestimmt ganz fröhlich bis dahin
tschüss
[Musik]